hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapter eight of
the categories concludes with a
discussion on Aristotle's part that is
bound to be a bit confusing when you're
first going through it particularly in
English translation if you don't have
access to the Greek text and this is a
discussion that bears on two different
categories that have quality to play on
and relation to prosty and their
connection with knowledge a piston may
now the Greeks distinguished all sorts
of types of knowledge and we're not
being very careful here to distinguish
between say a piss timaya scientific
knowledge versus techne as craft
knowledge or any of those those sorts of
things we're just thinking about
knowledge in general and Aristotle
earlier on in Chapter eight had said
that a piston may along with other types
of heck face were in fact qualities so
that was in fact the first type of
quality that he distinguished but
earlier in the chapter discussing
relation he also said that there that we
could think of knowledge is a relation
to the know
so this seems to raise a puzzle or a
problem and he says somebody could make
an objection to us we are including
terms that are treated as relations how
do we know they're treated as relations
because Aristotle did so just earlier in
another chapter within the category of
quality so what's going on here the
objector could be saying look Aristotle
pick which it's going to be is knowledge
a relation or is knowledge a quality
which which is it going to be and
Aristotle does what he so often does in
which so many other great philosophers
have learned from him he makes a
distinction now the way in which he
makes the distinction we want to walk
through this very carefully because the
distinction at first seems to solve
things but then when you look at the
ways in which he's explaining the
distinction it's bound to get a bit
confusing but if we look then at the
Greek it'll make a little bit more sense
and I'll explain that to you in just a
moment so we're really going through
three stages here's the solution as
Aristotle sets it out he says look the
genera the gaining are in fact relative
so when we think of knowledge as a gay
nose a type-a you know encompassing a
class of things that we have a term for
that is in fact a relation and all the
stuff that I did back in the earlier
chapter discussing knowledge as a
relation makes perfect sense however
when we're talking about particular
kinds particular bodies particular
disciplines of knowledge those are not
relative and the reason why I use the
term particular here although other
translations have individual is because
he is using the term cough acosta which
which you know we translate in that way
so he goes on and so far so good but we
don't really understand why the
particulars would not be relative so now
we want to get into his explanation why
why are the particulars not relative so
he says look knowledge itself the piston
may is knowledge of something hetero
we're going to come back to that very
important Greek term in a moment so then
the explanation goes like this he says
knowledge is knowledge of something
particular branches of knowledge are not
explained in that way for example we do
not define by a reference to something
external something else a knowledge of
grammar or music and we'll come back to
the greek that will make more sense of
that in just a moment but what i want to
point out here is we should read this
not just as something external at this
point but someone external some someone
who has it so he says for these if in
some sense relations can only be taken
for such in relation in respect to their
genus or of knowledge as such a piston
may that is to say we call grammar the
knowledge not grammar of something and
music we call in like manner the
knowledge and not music of something so
what is the point that he's trying to
make that when we use the term grammar
grammar is a subject right it and not a
subject in the sense of a thing that
underlies other thing people came in on
but what we talked about in our
contemporary English as a subject that
you can study what's going on when your
study you're learning a certain branch
of knowledge and that branch of
knowledge should allow you to be able to
use language in proper ways to identify
when language is grammatical and when
it's not grammatical so you can get into
arguments about ain't for example right
and you learn certain things like well
go to the dictionary or consult a you
know
grammar we don't usually use English
grammars unfortunately but we just have
nuclear languages so grammar itself is
in a certain sense not grammatical all
right it's not the grammar of something
it is of its knowledge of the grammar
likewise when we teach the discipline of
music the discipline of music itself is
of that subject matter music that we
perform you know think of individual
acts of music making or all that music
as a discipline understands those he
goes on and he says so particular
branches of knowledge are not to be
classed among relatives people are
called such-and-such from possessing
these branches of knowledge these are
the things they possess being therefore
called knowing that is a piston mon or
expert either either would work in in
this case right so we use this term at
peace timon of people who have a piston
may that is knowledge and when it comes
to the kinds of knowledge so you know
grammarian a government ecos is somebody
who possesses gras mati k which is a
knowledge a piston a of grotty k in
language right so there's a lot of
things going on here and he says
therefore these branches of knowledge in
virtue of which we are sometimes
described as of such and such nature
must therefore come under the category
of quality not relation what is it to be
a person who actually understands
grammar as most of us are right it is to
be grammatical in Greek to be
grammatical we could say or to be a
grammarian if
an expert in the field and that is a
quality of the person that derives from
possessing that knowledge which is of
grammar out there in language this is a
little bit difficult to wrap your head
around I want to come back to this
hetero thing because I think this helps
you to understand Aristotle's reasoning
and to see where perhaps he's making an
assumption that you might not entirely
agree with so he says here we go a
piston a knowledge as such as the genus
is in relation to something else hat
through and then he says told tone to
cough acosta un alto who as dean head
through Leggett type those things that
are of particular types of knowledge in
this case right we don't talk about them
in relation to a catheter ooh being of
something in this dis sense right so he
says so for example we don't say that
grammar is grammar of somebody else now
we could say that we could say so and
so's English grammar we're using grammar
then in a different and different sense
of the term we're talking about a book
that somebody wrote to convey grammar
grammar is still you know that that
stuff that's happening out there in
linguistic expressions just like music
is what's happening out there so he says
we call grammar the knowledge not
grammar of something right hoy own he
could a monte k they get to tinos apiece
to me it is knowledge of something but
it's not grammar of something if we want
to talk about the grammar of something
we would say the grammar of the English
language grammar of the
and tongue right and so Aristotle you
might think of them here is playing a
little fast and loose with language it
really does work in the Greek it's a
little bit harder to convey in the
English what it comes down to is
Aristotle at the very end he actually
says you know if somebody wanted to say
that knowledge in these specific senses
is both relation and quality I'm not
going to really have a problem with them
on that but he wants to assert that
particular branches of knowledge like
farming or reading Greek or you know
video production are in fact qualities
that the knower would have and which
could be predicated then therefore of
that no er rather than mere relations to
what it is that is known